check out this week's must-see movies  this is our time this is our chance to  make a different Pacific Rim uprising a  new generation of giant robot pilots  battle against a new giant monsters  there is a terrible evil in the world  darkness is spreading a persecutor of  Christians becomes an influential  preacher and teacher in Paul apostle of  Christ  I'm Sherlock gnomes sworn protector of  doubt and knows a detective searches for  missing ornaments in Sherlock gnomes who  needs a ship no [ __ ] Sherlock  see what's hot in theatres with this  week's fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]